my standards are creepy are much higher
we are at the end of the Los Angeles
Show we're saying hello to the last of
the people that are here and we have one
more friend
honestly like Tamizh discography stalker
and he's obsessed with us and every time
he comes over it's like what are you
guys talking but I'm in our last fan
that's having a thing right
[Music]
good morning in this Monday morning and
we are in this fun frenzies hanging out
with all her friends we are headed to a
shoot with mamrie for her new show on I
love makeup called picture day which if
you haven't looked at it you really
should because I think it's really I
love the concept and memories just
hilarious as a house essentially they
take one of your worst pictures growing
up and they recreate it and then they
show you how you should have done it
better and so I have sent them one of my
glamour shots from sixth grade and I'm
really excited to see how they recreate
it also because Mark Reagan is makeup
artist on the show who I got to work
with on Grace's faces the show on I love
makeup a few months ago and Wendy jdi's
is the hair lady yay let's go see them
good morning in a car again it is
Tuesday and we are headed to do
something unique and I hope it is fun
I'm gonna go record audio for my book
for the audio version of the book that's
right it's gonna be me reading the book
it's gonna be six hours of reading my
book out loud to strangers in the tiny
room today and six hours tomorrow and
this is time to bright panic because
breathing seems like real simple right
but then when you gotta do it flawlessly
in front of people so they can record it
and you can't pop your peas or slap your
teas or something I don't know I'm I'm a
little nervous to be honest
[Music]
yeah pretty great
very exciting business how to hang out
by yourself hanging out by myself is one
of my all-time favorite activities and
also one of my special skills along with
avoiding having to wear pants why does
my face look like a potato at Wednesday
and we are headed back for day two of
audio recording the second and final day
by now I think you guys have heard the
news that I'm really excited about that
I couldn't tell you guys about that
Hannah Hart and I are hosting the
Streamy Awards I'm all about that bass
bout that bass no we're super pumped we
have to write the things that we're
going to say and I'm a Berg I basic
called personality of the year audience
choice a thing of a person basically I
have got nominated in a category where
you guys can vote if you enjoy me as a
human there's a link down below for you
guys to go do that yep now I'm gonna go
and save my voice for the book now you
have to do it cuz it's caught on camera
hello it's another segment of fried iron
someone is there eating chips and
guacamole
very masculine life and this is Hannah
and I working on our streamys opening
monologue she's burning it and she's
burning our opening monologue into wood
so we never forget it
that's happening back there that is a
manly chair that you said you hated
[Music]
riveting riveting conversation hello
happy Friday to you guys it is Friday
morning and I'm really excited because I
just got a package and this package is
the mock-ups really represent its grace
shirts you guys to know there are
t-shirts out there that I'm really
excited about and they sent me some of
them and I finally get to see what they
look like in real life
oh gosh there's got to be an easier way
I'm talking about this but I'm gonna put
it on over here love it here's what I
like is that the sleeves are a little
long they can do that have a heart a
cool person thing and like roll up the
sleeves so that suddenly a very casual
t-shirt becomes quite stylish and dare I
say hip yeah sound like that you guys
can do it better
I've made a lot of merch in my day and I
gotta say I think I'm most excited about
this one it also comes in gray I like my
color schemes
the way dogs see the world everyday
white and grey so make sure that you go
to represent calm slush its grace
I think there's 12 days left of the
campaign to buy these shirts they're
$19.60 I did that just for you guys I'm
out of breath that's not a good sign hi
guys now we're gonna go do something fun
I am going to try clothes on for the
Streamy use I'm all about that bass bout
that bass no girl event dress me for all
the photos that are in my book is
dressing both Hannah and I named for the
streamys and she's picked out some stuff
and I'm excited to go put it on my
person let's do it there's little
Elizabeth yeah this is for me and this
is for Hannah you can very much tell the
difference I think and Hannah's getting
here soon so then we're all gonna try on
clothes he bidding is done went really
well some really pretty things that I
didn't show you any yeah but there is
already and now I am going to go edit
this video and post it for you that's
nice
over having a great Friday and if you're
not having a great Friday I hope you
turn it around somehow
then real motivational grace why does my
face look like a potato